today we are going to do an interview is
gonna feature puppies oh yeah there's
the one coming red little red ok fans
questions let's see are you gonna read
it you're gonna read a red you're
stranded on a desert island oh you're
good you're a hairdresser huh you're
stranded on a desert island which of
these people you've worked with before
do you want with you Tyler Perry Octavia
Spencer Terrence Howard or Brad Pitt I'm
gonna go with Tyler Perry because he has
its own private jet which one which one
you pick a belt you think you like that
yell Becca what character have you
enjoyed playing the most well your
career and why I think I would have to
say Vernell Watson from talk to me
because she was flyy she was the 70s up
we have our next question the movie was
set in the 70s and I loved her wardrobe
but she was she was the real cookie
what's your biggest deal-breaker when it
comes to relationships chewing on the
ears flying you can't lie to me
if you do I'll turn into my Linda oh
this was too long whoever that is I'm
not answering that
that's a paragraph what is the craziest
or scariest thing that happens to you on
set while filming acrimony these puppies
right now yeah I get my wienie funny I
guess the scariest thing I had to do was
to jump in this pool in the middle wee
hours of the night or morning and oh
that was another movie next question can
you share one funny or embarrassing fact
that most people don't really know about
you I'm kind of gassy do you want to
come on with me now you try to come on
with me when we don't call you
I spent some time with you for sale
misty misty misty we have read okay at
Francie and misty did I do good I think
I did good
can you figure out who's read right can
you figure out who's misty misty will
know what we doing we doing okay so it
says acrimony has a lot to do with being
able to truly living dog truly being
able to let things go what advice do you
have for someone to be able to really
just move forward and move on see that's
your that's a great question for you I
would tell people that if you spend so
much time in your life looking back you
can't get to what's in front of you you
can't get to what's ahead of you because
you miss the great things that await you
look poppies they moving on just move on
just move on what are some of the
weirdest jobs you had before becoming an
actress I was a singing dancing waitress
I wouldn't call that very weird because
dancing waitress yeah on a riverboat
[Music]
which celebrity makes you laugh the most
Kevin Hart all of these puppies are
available for adoption at North Shore
Animal League of America adopt adopt
don't shop and their faces are beautiful
yeah yeah Raja's take it all for home
you know how much I travel I don't have
a private jet you gonna help me with
that mr. bear and get this and we're
done keep recording
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]